[Music]
okay
[Music]
jesus nope not jesus it's just me
what the hell is going on oh yeah um
yeah i was working on this program and
um yeah
i i think i figured it out i think i got
the formula so basically if
you merge the projection equation wait
wait wait
what are you doing oh right
um okay let let me just show you
let me just finish up real quick
[Music]
ready
[Music]
wait i i i don't follow this is that
it's a donut
it's incredible isn't it
so so all this just
to render a donut on your terminal
what the [ __ ] thanks for watching
the idea and code were originally from
the amazing andy sloan
where he was able to code this whole
program and see
and made the code itself look like a
donut
he has an article explaining how the
code works which i'll link
in the description so why is math
important for programming
well it's because even if 99
of the time you won't need it there's a
one percent chance that you might
and it's in those moments that separate
out a great programmer
from average ones and if you do know
your math
you'll know how to modify this donut to
increase the size
change the rotation or even make a cube
instead
also if you want to do computer graphics
machine learning or cryptography
you're gonna need math so might as well
get good at it
as you did for programming anyway back
to the donut
how do we write this program well first
you have to create
a donut which is essentially a solid of
revolution
where we have a circle that rotates
around the y-axis
which will make a donut aka a tourist
this is the formula to create the circle
centered at r2
with radius r1 and this
is the rotation matrix to rotate this
circle
around the y axis so when we combine
them
we get the coordinates of every point on
your donut
now that we have a donut shut up i know
this is a bagel
now that we have a donut we want to
rotate it around the x
and z axis so it looks cool all flying
and stuff
we can do that by multiplying our donut
coordinates with
these two rotation matrices
now we have to map this 3d flying donut
onto a 2d screen which will become our
terminal
so each character on the terminal will
be a pixel
on the screen to figure out how to shade
our donut
we calculate the dot product of the
surface normal
and the direction of the light so as you
can see
when the normal points this way it's way
brighter
and when it points that way it's way
darker
so the dot product will tell us how
light or dark it is
we take the result of the dot product
and map it
into these characters from darkest to
brightest
and lastly we draw that on our terminal
and voila
if you like the way i teach you can
check out my new course on data
structures and algorithms
where i use easy to understand
animations to explain these concepts
the first 100 people to sign up for joma
class will get
15 percent off joma class